foreign
[Music]
just to kind of set the stage you know
we're going to have this conversation in
two parts I'm going to be talking about
the product
Enterprise search that we launched uh
and which is GA as of today and then
followed by that we'll have our panelist
here with Eva to talk about the search
use cases and how they're using this
Enterprise search in their day-to-day
business
so my name is Sachin and I am
the director of product for Enterprise
search offering at Google Cloud
excited to talk to you about you know
what we are doing in this space of
Enterprise search when you really look
at it you know for a long time
customers were used to Google and they
were like hey why can't I get that
Google kind of experience either on my
own website that I or the apps I have or
for my own internal employee and
knowledge sharing right and content
management so we had this question for a
long time around how do you how do you
provide this Google Search experience to
Enterprise customers and that's the
mission where we started of providing
access to information whether it's your
own website digital Properties or our
own internal employees and other search
places and that's got accelerated with
the introduction of what's happening in
large language model and foundational
models so you have launched a platform
and I'll go a little bit uh deeper into
it on the product side where we have
Enterprise search capabilities which can
have capabilities like natural languages
right where it's not only keyword based
but the same queries that you ask on
google.com you can use it either in an
internal search spaces or you can use it
on your customer facing websites we have
introduced new models for summarizations
with citation and this morning you saw
kind of an experience of that if you
were in the keynote where uh you know
ninshad talked about finding and
renewing your license on DMV website
where you kind of saw the summarization
of the answers and then also the
citation of all the links that went
through it right obviously there's a
follow-up so we have worked on kind of
keeping the state of the conversation
between two queries and you can have
more of a conversational experience as
part of that search
so that's where search is going so when
you really start with you know
uh
uh one sec
okay the formatting of the slide looks a
little different but when we started on
this we started thinking about who are
we building this search for are we
building it for the developers are we
building it for the practitioners of AI
and data and one thing we realized was
we wanted to kind of build a platform
which can
satisfy the needs of folks on the
developer side who really want to build
an out-of-the-box experience where it
can plug and play
and you know I'll get a search API that
I can call and it will manage everything
for me from data ingestion to indexing
to giving me the results on the other
hand we are do understand Enterprises
have some complicated use cases when
they want to build their own search
experiences maybe they want a vector
search they want to have their own
embeddings and all other things so how
do we start building a platform which
caters to the needs of both Enterprises
with Advanced analytics folks who want
more of a platform components as well as
Enterprise developers who really want to
focus on building and getting an API
which is more out of the box solution
and which is most of a managed service
so that we have built this platform with
taking these two personas in the mind
developers and AI practitioners I'm
providing enough of tuning and
customization so folks can move from
left to right or right to left so that
was the vision of how we started and
building this platform these two
personas in terms of the use cases that
we are really solving for we're solving
for primarily two use cases
both customer facing search as well as
and internal employee search
traditionally when you think about
Enterprise search you always I think
it's associated with internal employee
search but in this case we are using an
expansive meaning of Enterprise search
which is surge that's required by an
Enterprise doesn't matter whether it's
external customer facing or internal
internal employee facing search
and we'll go a little detail into kind
of like what are the use cases we are
seeing for search today uh in terms of
the use cases right primarily when we
think about the use cases that are we
are serving on the external use case
it's the public website search
which is what the example of DMV was in
this morning where it's easy for you to
create a Google kind of experience on
your own individual websites within
couple of minutes literally give us the
URL of what you want to build we'll
crawl it we'll keep uh we'll index it
and search API will be ready and then
you can you know enable search on your
own website uh and it's available in a
single turn multi-turn different kind of
abilities it has its own llm
capabilities that are built in as well
the second part of customer facing
search are really around catalog search
right in catalog we have different
versions of the product one is where you
can actually bring any catalog you know
there's no schema enforcement you get to
Define your own schema you get to Define
your own decks and we'll make a search
available for more of a structured
catalog on the other flavor of catalog
is where we have specialized searches
that we have built whether it's a retail
search a lot of big retailers across
across the globe are actually using
Google retail search today where you
know you bring in your retail catalog
and will enable search on top of it and
that search will be optimized for either
you know Revenue per visitor or some
kind of Matrix
so that's another use case that we have
been serving and these are just not the
four use cases there are many more use
cases but these are just a high level
use cases Eva and the team later on from
mayo and World Bank will kind of get
into the details of different use cases
they are seeing from an internal worker
search you know really kind of the two
flavors that I wanted to highlight here
at high level is around a document
search
so this is how do I have this
information spread in you know multiple
PDFs and documents across and each time
I have to get an answer for something I
have to open this maybe I have 10
versions of this Dock and five versions
of these slides how do I get something
that helps me get information from all
of these and somebody summarizes me this
information across right so that's the
document search that we are seeing and
we have enabled as part of our platform
and later on the panelists will talk a
little bit about what they are using
this for in terms of documents we are
seeing this interest from across a wide
variety of Industries in terms of the
last bucket which is more about your
traditional intranet search right which
is around here I have a I have a bunch
of documents which are behind a
restricted site and I need access to
this and I almost want a Google kind of
experience where all of my information
and content is available for knowledge
Discovery and this is where we are
enabling our intranet search where you
know you can use this search to really
go across uh whether it's a Google
workspace or other productivity tools
and other documents to get a search
enabled
uh we already had a product in this
space it was called Google Cloud search
it was part of our workspace solution
Suite we are taking it over and we are
porting it over as part of Enterprise
Search application you'll see start
seeing a lot more capabilities on that
product we've already had that product
already has capabilities on Ackle which
is required identity management and a
bunch of things but you'll start seeing
more capabilities like multi-turn search
summarization with citations and other
capabilities that will happen on this
product
so in terms of
uh
you know the vision of where we really
want to go and this just talks about you
know the ninja example that we had in
the keynote this morning we really
wanted
Enterprises is an easy way to build
search and get Google quality results
and that has been our number one goal
how can every digital property in the
world and every organization in the
world get access to their information
as they have come to expect from their
daily experiences on google.com
the second thing that we really wanted
to focus was on how do we get ground
ground our search results in our
Enterprise Corpus right we want to give
the flexibility for Enterprise customers
to Define what that Corpus looks like
and they can decide to be restrictive on
their own Corpus or be a little more
expansive with maybe you know uh
related Affiliated data sources that
they trust so we wanted to give this
kind of control back to Enterprises of
making sure that they have their
information and control over the data
sources
the other things we really wanted to
focus was on
giving proper access controls this is
very important for Enterprises that
certain visibility is only available to
certain people and that's been one of
the important features as part of our
Enterprise search that your manager
should be able to see some information
that you as an employee may not be privy
to or not allowed to a important part of
building any kind of search in the
system is data
and especially for an internal employee
search or other places where you've got
to index across a multiple sources of
information we wanted to build an easy
experience and that's where you know
today we'll get a little bit more into
the details of what data sources are
available but we are we are actively
incorporating a large amount of data
sources where it will be easy where
plugins will be available and connectors
will be available to bring in data from
multilued of Legacy systems as well as
SAS systems into our environment for a
easy built of search
finally fourth thing is a lot of
exciting things are happening in this
piece of vector search and that's where
we are rebranding and relaunching our
platform of vector search which was
previously called matching engine and
we'll go a little bit detail into what
we are doing with our Vector search
approach uh really useful as I mentioned
earlier about how we think about our
platform strategy right from out of the
box applications to Enterprise
developers who are from ml practitioners
who want to use the platform approach
Vector search is an important part of
our platform approach for folks who want
to build their own search on top of our
platform uh finally I think one of the
most important things is we wanted to
provide that customization ability right
we understand every Enterprise is
different some Enterprise wants to get
into details of something some want a
little bit more abstract things so as
part of that we are providing a lot of
flexibility on our platform if you know
we are providing you confidence course
on our retrievals so you can actually
look at this confidence course and make
a summary judgment hey maybe I'm you
know as a company my threshold for
confidence score is 90 and I'm only
going to show results about 90 as well
as summarize them as part of the
Snippets or I might say okay I'm okay
with 60 or 75 confidence score so we are
going to turn in more give you more
information about the stack and then you
can make information
useful on how you want to customize your
search results so that's been the vision
of how do we provide you something not
only out of the box but all the way to
building it your own search to somewhere
in the middle providing you the levers
and the tools and the signals like
confidence course so you can actually
decide how do you want to enable that
search experience
so that's been our Primary Vision for
launching uh platform in terms of
roadmap you know this is not an
expansive list of things that we have
launched up till now uh what we have
launched is a generative search with llm
capabilities and as part of that
generative search we already talked
about grounding it to your defined
Corpus of data the second thing is
multi-turn conversational search where
you're able to have a conversation and
state between searches
the standard features like autocompletes
spell check
you know query understanding query
intent all of those are already built
into our websites we are launching more
things on connectors and we'll talk a
little bit more about what new
connectors are coming into our space we
have configurations
that are available where you can decide
how do you want to boost Barry other
things and finally the most important
thing is providing you you know levers
for safety and search as well as
building an application which is more
focused on responsible AI
in terms of I think what's exciting and
what's coming soon and what was
announced today was some 3p connectors
right today primarily the integration
was done either through bigquery or
Google Cloud Storage but we are
announcing a net connectors for some of
the most popular ones right whether it's
Salesforce Confluence and jira and we
have a list of other connectors that the
team is building through uh just FYI the
connectors will be launched in in a
preview mode not in a ga mode in the
next two weeks uh we are also announcing
the confidence scoring which is again
available in preview mode and coming
soon
uh actually it was available today
uh
all the information is actually a is
available on our site and later on you
know everybody is going to flash our URL
or you can Google it where we are you'll
be able to find a lot of information
from our product perspective on what's
uh what's available and what's not uh I
wanted to kind of highlight few things
which are really exciting to talk about
uh which I'm personally getting excited
to talk about one of the things is
around adapters
uh you build a unique technology of
adapters where you can actually use
Simple golden data sets of question and
answers to improve your search quality
results
uh these might be this is just a sample
of queries you know mocked up by us so
don't look into the validity of whatever
it is but as a user think about it like
you can actually say this is my question
and this is my answer and you can say
Okay thumbs up or thumbs down we have
more of a range of scoring actually it's
one to you know zero to five scoring or
minus two to two plus two scoring
approach and then
based on the scoring that you give the
model is learning what is a good answer
and what is a good summarization so this
is uh this is something that we are
excited to make it available part of an
Enterprise search where you get to tune
the quality of your results based with
easy thumbs up and thumbs down approach
and this adapter will be very specific
for your search result and your project
that you have created so as a customer
you get to have an adapter that is
really tuned to your data and more than
that like if you have five different
search applications within you can
actually Define a different data sets
for each one of them in terms of what
adapters you want to train maybe for
your external customer facing shares you
know you have a different q a and golden
data sets for an internal it's different
and within internal you might have
different data sets so you can literally
build custom adapters at each of the
project levels
the next thing is obviously kind of
what's happening in the vector search
space uh you know as I mentioned earlier
we are
rebranding our matching engine and car
relaunching it as a vector search one of
the unique things
about our Vector search
is our ability
to
scale
and provide that Enterprise readiness
of high QPS and that has been something
very unique for us and very very proud
it's the same Vector search
infrastructure that powers google.com so
imagine uh you know we have some of the
world's biggest customers and retailers
who are actually using this actively
because we couldn't find that kind of
scalability and power with other Vector
search applications that exist in the
market today so we are excited about
that we are actually doing a lot of
changes you know introducing a lot of
changes with the product we are going to
go and provide more easy documentation
we want to cut down the indexing time
from what it exists today we want to
make it in couple of minutes this is
already a ga product so we are going to
introduce more enhancements where you
know you can start building your index
within few minutes as opposed to waiting
for you know a longer time we are
working on kind of changing the whole UI
experience and making that onboarding
much easier for customers who really
want to use our Vector search and we've
seen a lot of customers in this space
are really kind of the AI ml practice
who are building their own search for a
particular application right where you
know it's really unique in the way it's
been built
so these are some of the exciting things
that are coming up from a roadmap
perspective as well as the vision for
the product which is to serve the needs
of customers doesn't matter if you are a
Enterprise with a lot of data scientists
and unique skill sets and you want a
platform to build your search on or
you're more of a you know Niche
Enterprise who wants an out of the box
solution which is managed or you're
somewhere in the middle where you want
an out of the box solution but enough of
ability to customize your search for
different applications and play to the
needs of your uh you know use cases with
that I'm going to give it over to my
colleague Eva and the panel to talk
about the use cases
thank you very much Saturn use case
landscape is uh endless probably after
hearing to Sachin nude comeback and
we'll have as many use cases as people
in that room or even more since a couple
of you will come back with a couple of
use cases within your Enterprise
environment
um having said that
working with multiple organizations over
the past months we've done we've seen
some common themes and
these are just examples that you might
associate your organization as well with
the first one is conversational Commerce
and recommendations and that doesn't
limit itself to retail only that applies
to any segmented Market where customers
are now having those packaged solutions
for them and package products but now
with the search capabilities will be
easily able to search for additional
products and customize their their
portfolio of products they want to
select the other one is such an alluded
to that before is document and media
search Enterprise search allows us to
really select and
answer specific domain questions from
the variety of sources whether this is a
PDF
unstructured structure data and so on
and so forth creates that Vector
representation and ask specific domain
went to the model and the other aspect
is a website search navigation and in
that area any Enterprise has a website
allowing your customers to really search
through that
website in a more efficient manner time
to resolutions of crucial value and drop
off kprs are really hitting many of our
organizations so allowing that faster
resolution faster inside navigation
through the website is really key and
the next aspect is market research
of the organization has some market
research capability capabilities and
needs so being able to drive through
summarization through content generation
the insights that you can give to your
organizations is of huge importance and
drives productivity improvements and the
last piece that we want to highlight is
employee assistance being able to drive
productivity improvements through
providing the assistance to any
employees whether this is cloud search
that was uh that satin talked about or
even agent assist uh and kyc
capabilities on any of the consumers in
the call center these are the use cases
we have been seeing
and eventually
what does the impact of solving of those
business problems and we ask ourselves
how do we measure the value of that and
customer experiences Improvement in
customer experience is one of them
whether it's this uh net promoters
course or other kpis that we you might
look in your organizations productivity
improvements we alluded to that as well
driving through insights faster time to
resolution and faster time to insights
tend to Value provides additional
aspects process optimization that also
comes back to
allowing your users and your customers
to drive the search to the transaction
and completing an order or a payment and
and last but not least scalability
competitiveness we have seen that those
organizations start embraced that
innovativeness in their environments are
able to reap higher Revenue sources and
drive competitiveness
but uh before we talk too much about it
I would like our guests to speak to that
and invite them on stage so the first
one is
um didymia kozlowsky who is a solution
architect for Mayo Clinic Cloud which is
a platform for established by
Partnership of Mayo Clinic and Google to
transform Health Care with capabilities
of Google cloud and has more than 15
years of experience in healthcare and AI
welcome on stage
and the second person I would like to
invite is Raman
perumal who is a seasoned technology
industry professional with over 20 years
of experience working at the World Bank
he currently serves as the lead of the
artificial intelligence and machine
learning platforms teams where his team
is focused on harnessing the potential
of AI to enhance the efficiency and
productivity of Frontline worldwide
staff welcome on stage
thank you
so we are going to start with a question
we talked a lot about the use cases what
are the use cases that you are seeing in
your organization's while experimenting
with Enterprise Merit over the past
months and I will start with the Dania
well Mayo Clinic releases a number of
use cases for Enterprise search just to
give you a flavor I'll tell you about
three of them for our patients and
visitors we're looking at Enterprise
search on our public website so they can
take advantage of that natural language
interaction and The quick summary
without having to read the search
results for internal Mayo staff who are
loading knowledge bases into Enterprise
search like our policy documents and our
it knowledge base so you'll be able to
ask Enterprise search what's the dress
code when attending a conference or how
do I get access to Google Cloud
uh and then a third use case for
clinicians and researchers is we're
loading clinical documents into
Enterprise search we have years worth of
full-text documents from patient visits
surgical notes radiology and pathology
reports that really represent a wealth
of knowledge but it's hard to access
with traditional search methods and
almost prohibitively time consuming to
try to read manually so we're really
hoping that Enterprise search will let
us realize the full value of that data
set
and the follow-up questions immediately
how do you measure that value
coping is one thing measuring what you
measure you control well there are three
or three different ways that we measure
it the first is we're really looking to
provide a joyful search experience not
just a search that gets the job done but
one that's a pleasure to use and
certainly in my experiences Enterprise
search meets that we'll also get
customer feedback on that area
the second value add that we're trying
to get is Time Savings
the the summary is a great feature for
that because you don't always have to
read the individual search results you
can just get your answer right away and
then something like this huge data set
of clinical documents being able to find
the ones that you need really quickly
even if you then have to read them but
there's also summary features in
Enterprise search for individual
documents
the third way we measure value is more
quantitative and this is we need to be
sure it's giving correct answers so
we'll test Enterprise search against
known right answers and measure the
reliability and precision
or the recall and precision sorry yeah
so it's truly a combination of measuring
the performance of the model and the
performance of the summarization and the
business metrics right that you need to
look at Roman how is that in your case
what are the use cases and how do you
measure the value of
implementing those use cases sure thanks
Eva the World Bank I think we pride
ourselves in being a knowledge
institution so a lot of focus on
analysis so any analysis as with any
organization it starts with a search so
if you are able to provide a generated
summaries that kind of takes us a
significant way interrupt users having
to click on Blue Links find it out for
themselves the second piece is we also
produce a lot of information and if
you're able to use the outputs of search
to generate zero drafts to get our Pro
processes kick-started that was that was
another one and it would be Priceless to
have conversations with 70 years of
knowledge and research which the World
Bank has put together not just for
internal staff but also for the public
in general so that is those are kind of
the key use cases which we have focused
on okay and how are we measuring the
measuring of values pretty much aligned
with what they spoke about it's a lot of
measurements on the search performance
the quantitative metrics on Precision
recall customer satisfaction surveys
which go out but then for the knowledge
products it's going to be more towards
the time to market the time to move from
one process stage to another because it
takes a significant amount of time and
if we are able to measure and bring that
time down it brings greater value for
every dollar which the World Bank
invests in development yeah so this is
exactly what we are seeing in many of
the clients and probably you can
identify with those metrics are pretty
common independent of the industry right
and we encourage as well customers to
think about it up front before they
start launching before they start eating
the POC uh proof of concept to really
think about those metrics
um
I know we have been working for a while
so it would be interesting to hear and
what was your experience so far and what
are the wish lists that you you have for
us we always listen to our clients and
try to implement the best we can
so uh
I want to First say that Enterprise
search is coming out with wonderful new
features every day vpcsc support for
example just came up out earlier this
month we were very excited by that one
half of our list for new features were
some of the ones that Sasha talked about
a little earlier we want more connectors
to ingest data from a variety of data
sources so we're excited about being
able to crawl intranet resources and
ingest data directly from existing
knowledge bases and search stores
another thing that's on our list was the
uh
confidence scores we've been waiting a
long time for that I'll probably be
testing them in the hotel room tonight
yeah this has been a request indeed uh
for many of our clients we are excited
to launch it today and encourage the
group as well to try it out yeah Ramen
on your side so on the World Bank side
also it's very similar I think
connectors connectors connectors because
we have so many different enterprise
software which we use in different areas
uh right now a significant chunk of time
is spent bringing that data and
harmonizing it prepping it as Sachin
pointed out getting it into either a
bigquery or on Google data store so
having these connectors would greatly
help accelerate the value because the
expectation from staff is that they go
to one place and they're able to get all
the information at one place and that is
something which would be really helpful
the second piece which we've heard from
World Bank staff is an integrated view
of internal and external content because
right now they do use the public Google
they end up using the internal search
engines as well and they call it but
when you're producing summaries if
you're able to bring the power of both
grounded on citations I think that would
be awesome so that's
that's definitely something that we are
looking into implementation as well
working into testing and with our
clients so thank you very much for that
feedback
um and last piece I wanted to touch upon
uh there is a huge difference between
bringing uh generative Ai and AI
technology in general to Enterprise
environment from the b2c business
what are the governance structures that
need to be in place in your
organizations that the team here and the
audience can learn from that you've
implemented while working with that
technology over the past months
so maybe I'll go first so the world the
World Bank is kind of unique because we
have we enjoy certain privileges and
immunities as an International
Development institution but that also
means that when we work with cloud
services and Cloud providers the data
which is provided is kind of secure and
separated from the rest of the content
and that implies significant security
policies uh grounding of the networks
and so on and so forth so that possibly
is probably the most critical piece from
a governance standpoint because we do
not want any of the data which is
provided to be used for the model
improvements and stuff like that because
it is uh kind of proprietary to the bank
the second piece is even though we enjoy
privileges and immunities we follow the
data privacy policies so there is
internal World Bank personal data use
policy and that again implies that usage
of data how's the data stored how is it
used how is it going to be used in the
future those all become extremely
critical from a governance standpoint
[Music]
what do you agree is so
yeah we really have remarkably similar
concerns to the World Bank for Mayo
Clinic the privacy and security of our
patient data is Paramount so any data
that we're putting in the cloud we're
looking for the services to be HIPAA
compliant covered under our business
associate agreement we want all data
protected by both user identity
management so Google Cloud IAM and also
networking controls virtual private
Cloud we're also looking for full
auditing and traceability on any data
that we load in the cloud more specific
to generative AI it's really important
that any data that's input into the
model as prompts or as user questions
doesn't feed the training of the public
model that that stays private and all of
Google's generative AI features meet
that criteria yeah we very much stick to
that notion that anything whether it's a
prompt the training data or even model
output these are or IP of the customer
and we wouldn't use that in training our
models so I hope this is an explicit and
I think this is a requirement not only
for us but for any technology
organization so that leads me to the
last topic of today's talk thank you
very much for being with us today that
was well very valuable to the topic of
to the topic of Enterprise Readiness as
mentioned before b2c and B2B are truly
I don't want to say different businesses
but uh I think there is a high bar for
making generative AI in particular
Enterprise ready and uh that becomes
even harder uh in the era of generative
Ai and why the reason is that the access
to the technology is being democratized
there are more animal people
capabilities are getting out of the box
in the past
machine learning engineers and data
scientists had only an exclusive access
to that technology today it's not the
case today people need to learn how to
prompt and sometimes they don't need to
learn how to train the model to use AI
technology so the set of opportunities
is larger but at the same time the set
of risks is also larger
um
so what are the critical aspects that
we've seen in Enterprise environment the
first one is control over IP and as I
was mentioned before anything
um that is prompt training data or model
output is truly your data and your
protected IP the second aspect is
grounding in factuality and that's the
unique risk of generative AI
um grounding and providing and avoiding
hallucinations is of importance that
might cause the reputation of the
organization if that's not adhered to
and we are providing those grounding
capabilities on your Corpus of the data
the other aspect is easy access to
responsible AI tooling and I will talk
briefly about it in later
this is not only about talking I want to
be responsible this is really in
operationalizing that and giving
Enterprises the real tooling to make
that happen
and the last piece is data governance
Safety and Security
within the cloud that is guaranteed as
as with all our products on gcp
so how are we approaching that from the
uh
um Enterprise search perspective first
any of our products that we are
releasing and we are releasing into GA
today is
um are monitored by the Independent
party of lawyers
legal councils ethicists product and
Engineers that ask themselves how this
product
can be misused rather than used and
before releasing that product we are
going through all those reviews the
other aspect is uh as I mentioned before
all that tooling that we are giving to
our Engineers but as well externally to
be able to use that
within application of generative AI
technology and I will give few examples
of that and the last but not least is
all the work that Google is doing and
ourselves with
the educational research and
organizations and providing and learning
from all of those organizations
ourselves to implement and provide those
toolings and uh best practices
so just to give a few examples that we
released actually today in experimental
is as you generate generate images we
provide uh digital watermarking based on
really really recent
um Innovation from Deep line
allowing to embed an invisible
Watermark behind the generated images
it's not visible to human eye but it's
uh it's traceable from the AP
perspective the other aspects are safety
filters that some of you might have
already worked but are truly an
important aspect of
revising the data the input but as well
the output giving the customers the
confidence scores as well how harmful
that content might be
and the categories that you might Define
are multiple ranging from war crime to
violence
sexual harassment and so on and so forth
the third aspect I want to bring to our
attention is
biases so a lot of tools on our
responsible AI
website are available and um
for uh to prevent any biases whether
this is gender race religion
um you will be able to in a similar
manner to head as well and adjust the
confidence course
for your application and business needs
and the last piece that I want to bring
to your attention or recitation checks
so whenever the text is being generated
we are providing tools that allow to
monitor how much of that text might have
been copied so which gives you as well a
certain level of insight into
protecting the IP of of the original and
how how the model is being used to
generate new content
so
I want to pause for a second and if say
technology is great but
responsibility is even more important so
if there's anything that would take from
this presentation is that we all need to
use that great technology with huge
opportunities with huge responsibility
so successful II is only responsible AI
if you have any questions feel free to
check that website on Enterprise
specifically and thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign